would you like to introduce yourself to
the group
I'm the Prince of Malaysia
some call me The Dark One
other as the Lord of death
however
to most
I am known simply as
refills boss
I am
Dracula okay obviously we're dealing
with a little bit more than just
narcissism here
Renfield this is codependency 101
a narcissist will take full advantage of
a codependent's low self-esteem but
you're the one with the real power and
all you got to do
is take it back how do I do that
focus on your needs I mean I just
haven't thought about
any of my needs and years but if you
were to stop focusing on his needs what
would happen
if I don't
yeah what would happen stop focus on his
knees what would happen
he won't grow to full power exactly he
won't grow to full power what that's so
weird why would you phrase it like that
but yes he's right
[Music]
you win
who are you
you're signed by the church church I'm a
criminal my whole organization is about
evil
why are you here I'm here because I want
to
I'm trying to find this guy he stuck his
nose in our family business and killed
some of our guys trying to save a bunch
of innocent people roommate
servants
are serving you very well